[Music]
it was the warning heard across several
States take shelter a tornado is coming
this was just one captured on video the
National Weather Service issued 450
tornado warnings and as many as 65 were
spotted search and rescue operations are
still underway and the death toll is
expected to rise in Arkansas Alabama
Indiana Mississippi and Illinois
here the roof collapsed on a few hundred
people attending a heavy metal concert
killing at least one injuring dozens
some seriously now across a vast stretch
of the South and Midwest the cleanup
begins like a war zone I mean you can
look around the cars or windshields are
I mean these cars are moved they weren't
you know in the park that way and just
debris everywhere the scariest thing
I've ever been in if you was in an
airplane and had to take a higher
altitude and your ears seems like
they're about to blow that's what it
felt like it was a lot of pressure it
was quick though it was less than 15 20
seconds just seconds for this much
destruction this is a part of the
country that is used to tornadoes but
not usually this many at once it costs a
lot of money when you respond to
disasters of this size and we have so
many disasters that we are responding to
in fact I believe I heard this morning
about 16 major disasters across the
United States so it's a very costly
endeavor
power lines are down in several areas
leaving 250 000 people without
electricity and the storm that caused it
all also sparked fires in the South and
blizzards in the North
and as they begin to rebuild keeping
their eyes on the skies more storms are
on the way Patty culhane Al Jazeera
Washington